hey mites yet I have a surprise for you
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this Felix
it's your favorite game is it happy
wheels again no it better not be Felix
else I'm breaking up with your projects
but I see are you sure this game is so
much more than just hot babes okay this
game is about friendship volleyball and
having a great time
no it's my knee you don't get to play
now you get to play okay you're gonna
have to pick my girlfriend I mean my so
you pick you pick where you want to go
you press a circle to go somewhere you
want to go to the Jack of trades in good
choice perhaps buy some fabric a cheese
cake a crab perhaps by the crab mates
you really get in this game by the crime
come on by the crime
if I was an anime babe I would love a
crap in Agana bucks thank you okay can
you now shut the [ __ ] up about buying
crabs now go back with ex you can't
really do anything it's you buying stuff
so if you go
Tenerife it that's right it's Tenerife
it so go down okay you okay now we just
get to see her and for no reason I don't
I don't know what's happening I know
what what what why did you select my set
okay wait what oh okay I never done
these but I've heard about these you
have to take pictures careful you don't
wanna skip anything you skip that
what the hell all right so this game you
are running against each other okay so
pret you start pressing X as fast as you
can go not you faster not too fast you
fall you'll fall too fat too slow go
faster marzia what do you doing
I built a reputation you don't even know
who you are no you're not you're the
girl you're ruining my high score I
built hours of relationships in this
game we fail you fail the mission failed
how did I even play that's right I don't
I don't know I'm trying to figure it out
hey it's the twelve-year-old in the
games
good job Japan tranquil Beach sounds
good doesn't it sure okay and then pick
why you pick one of the rival okay this
is quick okay what that's quick what
does that mean like not mountain
climbing I never done this I've tried to
find this how did you find these which
one was it
we're gonna miss you as you do under
Holley he's ready yeah come on don't die
what happens if you fall why are you
doing this I kind of want her to fall
and die and break her neck the voice
acting is amazing I don't know I just
want to tell you you're okay I don't
know how you changed character how would
I know these things let me show you how
it's how it's done I could take pictures
whoa how do I do this
oh now you're playing the game go faster
you're winning merchants amazing yes now
you can pick now you can pick I think I
preferred that one yeah the one looks a
bit strange what why why all right oh
come on
oh you did what is happening if we fall
in you're dead stop dip stop [ __ ] come
on come on
[Music]
you